je fais 125 kg ça me regarde je le vis
comme je le vis je prends pas ça comme
mode de vie ce n'est pas un mode de vie
et de crocs être obèses c'est
certainement pas quelque chose que je
souhaite à qui que ce soit à 16 ans
j'étais en léger surpoids mais j'étais
hyper sportive en fait j'étais j'étais
très musclé j'étais assez massive et
j'étais petit
donc un peu un peu trapu et jeu complexe
est un peu à bas à propos de ça et en
parallèle bas c'était la puberté qui
commençait et puis ben j'avais juste
envie à la rentrée des classes de mmes
acheter de belles fringues et d'être
belle et et d'être comme tout le monde
en fait il se passe que bunge entrer
dans du 40 et qu'à la rentrée je
rentrais plus dans du 40 jours
entraînant du 42 donc j'ai acheté un
jean dentelle 42 et puis puis ça a été
le début de ses angoisses de passer du
42 au 44 et du 44 au 48 et du 48 52 et
donc je suis allé voir un médecin pour
perdre du poids je suis allé voir un
spécialiste et donc le médecin me dit
que j'ai 15 20 kilos à perdre
il me fait un bilan hormonal et il me
diagnostic une maladie que je n'ai pas
en fait il s'est trompé il m'a
diagnostiqué une maladie de la glande
surrénale il se trouve que sept ans et 7
ans doctrinaux log plus tard on a
découvert qu en réalité j'avais un
syndrome des ovaires polykystiques sauf
que entre temps ça a été ça a été une
errance médical une errance de
diagnostic et j'ai eu des traitements
hormonaux qui m'ont fait beaucoup
grossir le premier traitement hormonal
m'a fait prendre 28 kilos en trois mois
et en parallèle il a fallu perdre ses 28
kg et les quinze à 20 kilos qu'il
estimait que j'avais en trop suite à ces
régimes trop restrictif mon rapport à
l'alimentation a complètement ouvriers
c'est manger en grande quantité sur un
temps assez réduit et c'est pas c'est
pas mû par la fin c'est pas mu par de la
gourmandise c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui est compulsif
on mange comme on pourrait taper
quelqu'un en fait mon rapport à la
nourriture c'était un rapport de
d'autodestruction c'était un rapport de
violence que je m'inflige et ses crises
là je peux les comparer à des crises de
scarification clairement quand tu fais
une crise d'hypertension sait jamais
pour le plaisir le but c'était de me
retrouver dans d état semi comateux
c'était de me c'était d'oublier en fait
que j'avais mal
[Musique]
à 17% des français qui sont obèses à
partir de quel moment il ya une partie
de la population qui doit être
discriminé et est ce que ça vous semble
normal que ces gens là bas ne soient pas
représentés en fait c'est pas parce
qu'il est gros qu'il faut le discriminé
c'est pas de sa faute en tweed et oui
quoi enfin un peu mais pas trop et on a
qui justifie enfin c'est de leur faute
enfin c'est eux qui font par exemple qui
font pas grand chose du coup ils sont
dans leur canapé à manger n'importe quoi
et au final qu'ils arrivent à maigrir
mais y'en a qui ont des maladies alors
il arrive pas face du coup c'est pas
leur faute c'est important de comprendre
en fait que l'obésité c'est une maladie
multifactorielle où il ya la fois d où
il ya un an à la fois un terrain
génétique un terrain familial un terrain
d'éducation mais aussi un terrain
économique un terrain environnemental
on ne devient pas obèse par hasard
il
[Applaudissements]
j'ai retrouvé un jour dans un entretien
d'embauché ou le recruteur m'a dit que
le quotient intellectuel était
inversement proportionnelle à l' indice
de masse corporelle donc il
sous-entendait que plus on était gros
plus on était débile clairement dans
tout mon parcours professionnel
il n'y a pas eu une seule fois un seul
job où je me suis pas fait mal traités
quant au travail il y avait des débats
sur sur les sur les retraites
j'avais des remarques qui étaient à mes
gabriel elle aura jamais de problème de
retraite
elle trouvera dans sa graisse avant ça
ce sont des remarques qu'on peut
entendre en fait ce que ça engendre chez
certains gros c'est une phobie en fait
de dettes gros c'est une phobie de ce
monde triche connais des gens qui
mettent des pulls en été parce qu'ils
ont peur qu'on leur dise que leurs bras
sans trop gros moi j'ai grandi dans le
sud de la france où il ya des rivières
partout où il ya la mer pas loin où il
ya des piscines partout où tous tes
copains ont une piscine en fait
et toi tu n'y vas pas tu te prives de ça
parce que tu as peur qu'on dise que tu
as des grosses cuisses que tu est
dégueulasse qu'on fasse référence au
film sauvez willy que si tu plonges les
gens aient peur que sa vie de la piscine
aujourd'hui je n'arrive même plus à me
dire comment j'ai pu être impacté par
ces regards là qui m'empêchait de vivre
en fait personne ne mérite de se faire
du mal personnes méritent de vivre plus
personne ne mérite de se cacher parce
qu'il ya trois il ya trois zigotos qui
estime que tu est dégueulasse en fait je
pense qu'il est urgent que bat
l'ex-robin il se montre quoi qui mettent
des débardeurs qui mettent des shorts
qui se promènent à poil single en fait